have to ask about the leftovers i guess
kind of just
you know generally we know that it must
have been a very
emotionally challenging show to shoot
and damon has even said that that first
season was
you know maybe a little too depressing
so did you feel that yourself
and did you kind of welcome that change
in seasons two and three
i had a very specific idea about the
seat about
season one because i'm a big tom
perrotta fan
and i think of tom as a satirist tom is
very funny
and very dry and that's very present in
the leftovers the book
and i did feel that that season one of
of the leftovers tended toward the
humorless in a way that tom's writing
doesn't
so you could see that um tom's material
was sort of losing out against a
against a bigger aim and
i always tried to find the humor and i
always used to joke with them if nora
durst is your class clown then you might
be a little bit of trouble but
um but i do think that that season one
really sets us up to make those pivots
in season two and three in some ways
makes them even more special for how
they evolved
and in some ways maybe two and three are
a little closer to my
my personality as i was describing
earlier that i'm actually quite
quite light um but
but i think it's i've never seen a show
quite do what we did there i would love
to see a show that starts off as a drama
and then completely becomes a sitcom you
know but that's as close as i think i'm
gonna get
i feel like there's something to be said
for a show that also
knows how to pivot and has the guts to
pivot
rather than to stick to what you set out
in the pilot or the first season and
kind of keep driving
i think guts is a good word i think guts
is a really good word for it i felt like
that show was gutsy
yes and you might not agree with all the
choices we made but you couldn't deny
that they were
there were some really bold choices
absolutely i do have one
super spoilery question for the
leftovers for you
did you ever straight up just ask damon
if
nora is telling the truth at the very
end i never
i never asked i didn't ask a lot of
questions
mimi leader tells the story which i
don't tell to flatter myself but just to
illustrate how things were operating
i think she went to ask damon how they
were going to direct it and
and then she said oh never mind never
mind carrie will know what to do
they just left it in my hands and i
didn't ask
and now i think maybe i should have but
i came to find out later that a lot of
the other actors were asking a lot of
questions but i think because i come
from the theater
i don't question the writing generally
if i'm confused about something or
something doesn't feel
character driven to me i will always
raise that but i had so
few moments of that on the in the
scripts of the leftovers that it didn't
occur to me that i could
like go to them be like so what's and i
didn't know that's how it was going to
end
until i got the speech so i just worked
on it and did it
knowing what i felt and what i believed
and knowing that it wouldn't really
matter
the performance wouldn't necessarily be
different if you know one or the other
thing was true
because of the objective so no i didn't
ask
so but does that extend to how you
feel about it i mean i guess while
you're shooting it but also now do you
have to kind of make your decision and
close the book on it
i made my decision when i did it but
i've always maintained that i'll never
say what my decision was
because it will rob people of their
experience of it because of course the
show reveals more about you
than it does about me and so what kerry
the actor thinks is sort of
really just doesn't matter
[Music]
[Applause]